what are notes and how should a writer
approach getting feedback
well most writers are pretty nervous
when they are receiving feedback and it
can be a very stressful thing for a
writer to
walk into a potentially unknown
situation
usually the people that you're getting
notes from are
people that you've either first met you
don't have a relationship with just yet
at least in the professional setting
or perhaps you're in a writer's group
and
if it's a competitive environment that
can also be a very stressful
place sometimes and
one of the first things that we
do when we work with our clients is we
just
talk to them we help them to calm down
we help them to get comfortable because
in order to receive notes in order to
give notes there needs to be a level of
trust and understanding that the people
in the room are truly trying to help the
project
and
it's it's even though the process of
writing really requires writers to put
their whole heart and soul into
something this is not the time or place
to put your whole heart and soul on the
table it's time to step back and be
objective and
really think about what the project
needs not what the writer needs
that can be a hard thing i think that
one of the big messages of our book is
to the kind of subtext message to
writers is don't set yourself up for
failure
and one of the ways that writers set
themselves up for failure is they ask
the wrong people to give them feedback
on their work and we see this all the
time so wrong people to give feedback
would be people who
who really uh they they're your
cheerleader you know now at a certain
point you do you absolutely do need
cheerleaders in this field it's a very
demanding field and you need people who
just believe in you and tell you you
know you're going to get through this
and you're going to be great and i can't
wait to see your movies etc but you
don't give your mother your screenplay
and say you know
what do you think is it any good because
chances are unless she's mommy dearest
you know she's going to say this is
great you know and um and and then
people who know you too well they they
read between the lines you know and it
may not be on the page what they're
reading so one of the things is you know
a writer absolutely needs feedback at a
certain point because you you plateau in
your skills and and the idea of putting
your work in front of people who can
really help you take it to the next
level take yourself to the next level as
a writer and mature in your skills
realize wow this is you know i'm i'm
kind of on the verge here but i'm just
not getting into excellence in this
skill
people who know the art form who really
have the ability to uh to not only see
what's wrong with something but then
even analyze and say why it's wrong now
one of the things that we find in this
industry is uh sadly and it's one of the
reasons stuff gets
worse as it goes through the development
process
is that the people giving notes very
have very little command of the art form
itself
and that's something that a writer needs
to expect you know i've worked for
a whole slew of producers who didn't
know what i was talking about when i
said inciting incident or the first
turning point or the arc of
transformation you know any of the kind
of standard uh jargon that storytellers
right screenwriters use and i've had
producers just look at me blank-faced
and they say basically you know just
make it so that everybody wants to see
it and we make 10 million dollars you
know yeah like they don't care and the
truth is is that many projects are green
lit because somebody likes penguins or
somebody likes
princesses and it's all uh you know a
lot of it is based on personal taste but
that's not going to give you a great
story and
producers don't always have the story
skills to be able to separate what their
personal taste is from what a good story
is
and that so that really falls on on the
writer trying to interpret what these
notes are
and hopefully they have a strong um they
they have strong people around them to
help them navigate that process but it's
the writer really has to be a very uh
kind of like a an
or a seeker in the notes process they
can't take anything at face value so uh
i had a producer say to me not long ago
we're getting feedback that your script
is a c script
and i've read a lot of scripts my script
isn't a c script i knew it's not a
scripture it's not perfect but i knew it
was in a c-script so then i started
saying well what do you mean and uh and
you know we kind of went through this
whole thing where it turned out
basically only three people had looked
at it looked at it two of them were
people that weren't really had done
anything didn't know what they were
talking about and one was somebody who
whose favorite movie is kung fu
uh you know something it was like
nothing like this movie anyway so what i
found out was that the people that were
giving him notes uh were the wrong
people to really be assessing this and
and and he really didn't care he just
wants to sell the movie so i think that
that writers one of the things we're
trying to do in notes to screenwriters
is help writers hear a note
and then not take it at face value try
to get underneath the note to
you know what isn't happening in the
reader that should be that this note is
kind of signifying um so not to dismiss
the notes but also not to take them at
face value and and then you know when
you're when you're actually when you're
at the stage of just trying to get your
script ready the feedback that you
get
really needs to be tailored to your
growing and the project growing so
you've got to be careful that the people
you give your script to are people who
know what they're talking about you know
that some some medieval saints said once
a bad spiritual director is worse than
none at all and it's just true in
screenwriting too bad
uh notes are worse than none at all they
can really send you spinning but if you
are working with people who don't have a
lot of experience giving notes some of
the best notes that somebody like that
can give is something along the lines of
well this is where i dropped out or this
is where i
lost interest or this is where i didn't
understand
notes like that can be really helpful
for a trained writer because they can
then go back and look at those areas and
fix them
based on that kind of response
the number one thing to get past your
terror of notes is to get a lot of it
and we recommend every writer this
series should be in a writing group they
should be in this process where they're
getting feedback regularly so it so it's
not
the scary thing you know after you've
had your scripts read you know for three
or four years in a writing group you
just you get
you're able to separate yourself from it
and and so writers absolutely they need
feedback to grow
they've got to get used to feedback and
so they've just got to be in put
themselves in an environment where
they're getting good stuff so
being in a good writer's group with
other screenwriters who know the art
form who are also uh you know working on
their skills this is a we think it's
essential for a writer and with that
mentoring mentoring is is extremely
important for somebody starting out to
start to to train their own ear
in what kind of feedback is necessary
and proper at different stages of the
script